so Sean talked about this crazy method
of string compression called
burrows-wheeler that's going to let us
convert the repeats of the repeats of a
genome into runs so that then we can
apply some other compression like run
length encoding but say we do this
operation and we compress the genome and
then it's stored as a smaller file
somewhere but then when we download this
genome when we want to work with it
the question is we need some way of
decompressing we need to some way of
going getting the original genome back
and so the point is is that if we apply
run length encoding say for example it's
easy to decompress that
so if we see 14g then we can easily turn
that into 14 occurrences of gee but what
about going this direction what about
taking the burrows-wheeler transform of
some genome and reconstructing the
original genome is that even possible to
do ok and I think that you can think
about this for a second and maybe cut
maybe pause and come back but my my
thinking would be no I think that it
doesn't seem obvious how you would go
backwards give them this burrows-wheeler
transform string let's see though if we
can do it ok so say that we want to
reconstruct the original genome banana
I'll use a much smaller example than
panama bananas and here's the
burrows-wheeler transform of banana so
it's a n n be dollar sign a a now we're
assuming that we have this string but we
don't know the original string banana
okay how do we reconstruct so notice
that if you know the last column of the
burrows-wheeler matrix then we're going
to get the first column for free and the
reason is that because the strings are
sorted are lexicographically sorted
right there all cyclic rotations of
banana that have been a lexical
lexicographically sorted then for that
reason the first column is just the last
column that's been sorted ok so sort the
last column a gives you the first column
so you get dollar sign three occurrences
of a B - two occurrences of n so we get
another column for free
the next thing I want you to notice then
is that if we have the first column and
the last column remember that each of
these rows is a cyclic rotation of
banana so that means that this a occurs
directly before the dollar sign in that
cyclic rotation of banana this n occurs
directly before the a in that cyclic
rotation of banana and so on
right and you can see this from the
matrix that you can see is grayed out
right banana the next symbol is s dollar
sign ba na and the next symbol is a so
what this is going to tell us is we get
tumors of the cyclic string banana for
free okay so if we're looking at the
tumor composition of this one of these
cyclic rotations will get a dollar sign
here here we'll get na na and so on so
we get the tumor composition of this
circular string if we then sort this
tumor composition we get the string
shown that on the right this is going to
give us the first two columns of the
burrows-wheeler matrix and the reason is
that remember the burrows-wheeler matrix
the rows are sort of lexicographically
so if you sort the tumors occurring in
banana lexicographically then you should
get the first two rows here and I'll
highlight that right so the first two
columns should be dollar sign be a
dollar sign and so on and that matches
perfectly the sorted tumor composition
now we've got three columns okay can we
get a fourth and so we apply this exact
same idea so we say a must occur
directly before dollar sign B in the
cyclic rotation so that gives us a
dollar sign B and must occur directly
before a dollar sign so we know that one
of the three Mirza's n a dollar sign and
so on so we get the three more
composition of a circular string banana
and then we can sort that three more
composition to get a collection of three
MERS because they're sorted we know that
they must correspond to the first three
columns of the burrows-wheeler matrix
okay we go again we know that these
formers are a dollar sign ba and a
dollar sign B and so
we get the former composition we sort
that former composition that gives us
the first four columns we use those four
columns together with the final column
to give us the five more composition of
the circular string banana we sort those
five verse that gives us the first five
columns and then we do this one last
time to get the first six columns of the
burrows-wheeler matrix we take all six
MERS so a comes before dollar sign B a
and a and so on
we then sort those six mouths and that
gives us this first six columns and so
lo and behold we've managed to
reconstruct the entire matrix now that
we know the entire matrix we just say we
know that the dollar sign is always
going to appear in the top left because
remember we assumed that the dollar sign
is lexicographically first and now that
we've done this we can say everything
after the dollar sign must be our
original string so because the dollar
sign ends the string so the top row is
when you spell it out is going to give
us banana and we're done so we've
managed to invert right we started just
with the final column and we were able
to reconstruct the entire matrix just
from knowing the last column the issue
though is I know what Shawn is going to
complain about and that is that if we
have to reconstruct the entire matrix
the entire matrix is equal to the length
of genome in one direction times the
length of genome in the other direction
so this is going to give us genomes
squared right we're going to have
quadratic in the length of genome to
build this entire huge matrix to
reconstruct what the original genome was
and this is we again have memory trouble
here so the question is can we invert
burrows-wheeler can we decompress using
less space so let's make a strange
observation okay again remember that if
we start with the last column we get the
first column for free so assume that we
have those two columns but we don't know
we haven't reconstructed the internal
parts of the matrix now I've highlighted
the six occurrences of a and the first
column the six occurrences of a in the
last column and I've highlighted where
those occur in sort of the cyclic
representation of
bananas okay so if we look at the first
a in the first column and we look at the
first and the last column then you'll
notice that these two A's correspond to
the same position in the string Panama
bananas so it's the second it's the
third a in Panama bananas notice that
this is the first a second a third a
right first a second a third a so this
position and this position are the same
okay
the second second occurrence of a in the
first column second occurrence of a in
the last column
both of these correspond to the second a
in the string right so we have P a n a p
a na alright and so I've highlighted the
a here and so we can go through and we
through and we notice this same thing
the third occurrence of a in the first
column and the third occurrence of a in
the last column both correspond to the
same position in the string and so on so
we get all six positions and it's the
same all right we can look at the ends
too it's not just something that's
particularly to a it's for any for any
symbol so if we look at the ends the
first appearance of n in the last column
in the first appearance of n in the
first column they both correspond to
this end right and you can verify this
for the other two that this property
appears to be holding so the question
then is is this true in general before
we remember we wanted we want to know a
faster way of inverting burrows-wheeler
but for now I just want to know does
this property hold in general it's
interesting so let's go back to our our
burrows-wheeler matrix for panama
bananas and remember that the strings
are sorted so if we if we look at the
the six columns that start with an a all
right
then they're they're sort of as well
alright so I've numbered these off and
if we chop off an A then the rows are
still going to be sorted C so because
they all start with a the remainder of
the strings are still sorted all right
now if we add this a back to the end
then those strings should still be
sorted right because all we did was add
an
to the end of all of them okay so we've
essentially done a cyclic rotation of
our six original strings where we just
took the a and put it on the end and
those strings remain sorted so what that
means is if we look for those cyclic
rotations back in the original
burrows-wheeler matrix wherever they are
wherever they wind up being they should
still maintain the same ordering okay
and so that's what's saying if this was
the if this occurrence of a was here
then it has to be the same in the
original string as this occurrence of a
and so these correspond one two one two
two two and so on all right how can we
state this in general well we say the
Kate occurrence of any symbol in the
first column and the Kate occurrence of
any symbol in the final column of the
burrows-wheeler matrix they're going to
correspond to the exact same position of
that symbol in the original genome so
you can index your occurrences of each
symbol in the first and last column you
can index the six a's here and the six
a's here and that means that they
correspond to the same positions the
only other interesting symbol here is
the ends and we mentioned this before
but we can index n 1 n 2 and 3 and they
correspond N 1 n 2 and n 3 in the last
column ok so that's a really I think a
cool proof and an interesting fact but
the as I said the issue would be what
does it have to do with burrows-wheeler
decompression so let's see if we start
at the dollar sign on the top left of
the burrows-wheeler matrix then we know
that if we walk backwards in the string
so assume that we know parallel bananas
for a second and represent it this way
if we walk backwards in the string then
that corresponds to walking backwards
one position here and winding up in the
last column so we know automatically
that the position before the dollar sign
in the original string is an S by this
first last property that we've just
shown we know that that s has the same
position as this s ok in this case
there's only one s but if there were 190
SSE's we would know that this s and this
s have the same position so this s
corresponds to that s as well
all right and so now we can walk
backwards from this s right we know that
in the original string if we go
backwards in this cyclic rotation of it
then we'll hit the last column element
here and that's an a so we've walked
backwards from the s wound up on the
other side and were able to reconstruct
an A here before the S we applied the
first last principle again and say that
this is the sixth occurrence of a and so
here you're seeing why it's useful okay
we don't know if we don't have the first
last property we wouldn't know which of
these A's has the same position as a6
over here but because of the first last
property we're able to go straight to
this a and say that this a has the same
position in the original string mm-hmm
once we know that we walk backwards one
step and go around the cyclic rotation
and say that the previous element in
this cyclic string is an N so we're able
to walk through this procedure one step
at a time where we use the first last
property and then walk back a step
use the first last property and then
walk back a step and so on so we're able
to sort of reconstruct the original
genome in Reverse and so you can follow
this and we end up with panamabananas'
ok again we know that the dollar sign
ends the string so we go this way
so we've now reconstructed our original
string panama bananas using only the
first column first column and the last
column without needing to reconstruct
any of the internal elements of this
matrix so if we've used two columns of
the matrix then we've used memory
approximately equal to two times the
length of genome so we're now at Big O
of genome for ricans for decompressing
the burrows-wheeler transform and this
is great but I know what Shawn is going
to ask which is how does this relate to
pattern matching and I'm curious about
it too so hopefully he'll be able to
tell us what it is that this
burrows-wheeler transform which is
amazing stuff and I think from a
mathematical perspective is really cool
but what is it that it has to do with
pattern matching how is it that we could
possibly use it for pattern matching to
try and get the constants down in terms
of storing the fish
data structures for working with pattern
matching so hopefully he can tell us
about that